[Music]
that was the first time I saw her but
before we talk about her I have to tell
you something about me when I was nine
we moved to Myka Arizona that's the new
kid I became the center of attention
real fast and not any good way it was
then that I realized I was gonna need to
disappear no one would see me no one
would hear me I was gonna have to be
just like everybody else and then one
day tries to put me down
what's her name anyway star girls my
name is star girl so be sure to use your
tiger she likes you
she doesn't
[Music]
you like stocker I don't really know her
but maybe if you did you might won't you
let me walk you home from school mom
were you ever afraid of what people
thought of you figuring out who we are
is the one thing no one else can do
person won't you let me meet you
did you wanna ask basically if it's so
let me know sometimes I'm quiet but I'm
just thinking scream leo
why would I do that don't you want the
university hear you since you got here
things have been different some people
were just like that being with you is
the most anyone has ever looked at me in
my entire life
there's just something about her she's
not like anyone else
it's magic
you think things have to be real more
magic
[Music]
but the best thing
[Music]
our boss
[Music]